PEOPLE ARE STILL SUFFERING.
>>> AND CNN'S NICK PATON WALSH
JOINS US FROM A CITY NEAR THE
BLACK SEA IN SOUTHERN UKRAINE.
NICK, WHAT ARE YOU SEEING TODAY?
>> Reporter: JUST TO LET YOU
KNOW HERE, JIM, IN ODESA THERE'S
A CURFEW.
WE HAVE SPENT THE LAST 24 HOURS
IN MYKOLAIV THAT HAS BEEN UNDER
FIERCE RUSSIAN ASSAULT.
WE SAW THE HEROISM, THE GRIT,
THE DETERMINATION OF LOCALS
THERE TO LIVE AND TO RESIST THE
RUSSIAN FORCES.
HERE IS WHAT WE SAW.
THE BRIDGE HERE HASN'T BEEN
RAISED FOR AS LONG AS THEY CAN
REMEMBER BUT NEITHER HAS THE
SLEEPY PORT TOWN OF MYKOLAIV
INVADED.
IT IS LIKELY EXCHANGES WITH
RUSSIAN PARATROOPERS WHO WE'RE
TOLD LANDED NEARBY.
LOCALS STRUGGLING TO KEEP UP
WITH SOLDIERS EDGY.
THE FEAR HERE RUSSIAN SABOTEURS
LIKE THESE TWO SUSPECTS THROWN
TO THE GROUND BY SOLDIERS.
THEN THE SIRENS GO OFF.
AND IT IS BACK IN THE BASEMENT
FOR MOTHERS AND CATS.
HERE THE NOISE OF WHAT RUSSIA
WOULD DO TO THESE TOWNS IN THE
NAME OF SUBJUGATION.
TURNING LIGHTS OFF AND
BUSINESSES CLOSED IN A HURRY.
LIFE PERSISTING, CAUGHT BETWEEN
HOPING THIS IS SHORT-LIVED AND
WONDERING IF IT MAY GO ON
FOREVER.
BEHIND IT ALL, IN EMPTY STREETS
THE FEAR THEY MAY BE OVERRUN AND
WHETHER EACH HUGE BLAST WILL BE
THE DECISIVE STRIKE THAT LETS
PUTIN'S TROOPS ENTER.
THE SHELLING JUST WENT ON AND
ON.
THE NEXT MORNING WE SAW WHERE IT
HIT.
IT'S LIKELY A MISSILE TORE UP
THESE UKRAINIAN TANKS BUT NOBODY
LEFT FEELS BROKEN.
HOW DO YOU FEEL?
>> GOOD.
VERY GOOD.
>> Reporter: YEAH?
>> YEAH.
>> Translator: THEY TRIED TO
COME INTO THE TOWN.
HE'S SAYING THE RUSSIANS TRIED
TO COME IN BUT THE TOWN OF
MYKOLAIV BEAT THEM.
AND YOU CAN SEE WHAT IT LOOKS
LIKE HERE.
SAYING LOOK AROUND HERE.
I'M ASKING HOW DO YOU FEEL
LIVING HERE THIS IS WHERE YOU
LIVE, RIGHT?
LOOK AT THESE WINDOWS THAT ARE
BLOWN OUT.
[ SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE ].
>> Reporter: SO THE WORDS OF
RUSSIAN MINISTERS WHO HAVE BEEN
SAYING THEY'RE NOT GOING TO HIT
CIVILIAN INFRASTRUCTURE HERE,
HE'S REPEATING THEM BACK TO ME
SAYING, LOOK, LOOK AT THIS.
THEY SAY THEY'RE NOT HITTING
CIVILIAN INFRASTRUCTURE.
LOOK AT THE DAMAGE AROUND HERE.
PUTIN'S ROCKETS MAY HAVE
SHATTERED GLASS BUT NOT DENTED
THE ANGER HERE.
AS THEY TAKE STOCK, YOU HAVE TO
ASK YOURSELF WHY MOSCOW EVER
THOUGHT THESE TOWNS WOULD GLADLY
BE OCCUPIED AND WHAT RUSSIA'S
END GOAL IS.
TEMPERS FRAY HERE.
BLOOD HAS BEEN SPILLED BUT
DESPITE RUSSIA'S OVERWHELMING
FIREPOWER THEY DID NOT PASS.
JUST THIS AFTERNOON THE MAYOR OF
THE TOWN CALLED ITS CITIZENS OUT
TO FORM WHAT HE CALLED A
CIRCULAR DEFENSE AND TO GET
MOLOTOV COCKTAILS TO POTENTIALLY
FEND OFF ANOTHER RUSSIAN BID TO
GET INTO THE CITY.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU, JIM, WHAT IS
UTTERLY IMPOSSIBLE TO UNDERSTAND
IS QUITE WHAT RUSSIAN FORCES
THINK THEY'RE GOING TO ACHIEVE
BY THIS SORT OF BOMBARDMENT OF
DENSELY POPULATED AREAS.
YOU SAW THE DAMAGE INFLICTED ON
SOME PARTS THERE AND YOU HAVE TO
WONDER WHAT SORT OF FUTURE THEY
IMAGINE IN THESE TOWNS IF THAT
DAMAGE OCCURS AND THEY PUT SO
MANY LIVES AT RISK AND THEN TRY
TO OCCUPY THEM FURTHER DOWN THE
LINE.
STARTLING AND BAFFLING TO WORRY
WHAT THE PLAYBOOK MAY BE, JIM.
>> IT LOOKS LIKE IT MAY BE
FUELING THE INSURGENCY AND
RESISTANCE.
NICK PATON WALSH, THANK YOU FOR
THAT REPORT.
EXCELLENT REPORTING ON THE
GROUND.
>>> NOW TO JILL DOUGHERTY IN
MOSCOW.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT THIS
ALARMING ORDER BY VLADIMIR PUTIN
FOR RUSSIA'S DETERRENCE FORCES
TO BE ON HIGH ALERT.
THOSE FORCES INCLUDE NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
WHAT IS YOUR SENSE OF HOW THE
RUSSIANS ARE EXPLAINING THIS?
DOES IT HAVE ANY CREDIBILITY?
IT SOUNDS LIKE SABER RATTLING
AND PERHAPS A SIGN OF
DESPERATION.
>> Reporter: WELL, IT HAS
RELEVANCE.
HE IS THE COMMANDER IN CHIEF AND
HE DOES HAVE THE SECOND -- TWO
OF THE LARGEST, UNITED STATES
AND RUSSIA, HAVE THE BIGGEST
NUCLEAR ARSENALS IN THE WORLD.
SO WHEN HE SAYS THINGS LIKE THAT
IT IS VERY SERIOUS AND I THINK
THAT'S HOW IT SHOULD BE
INTERPRETED AND WHAT HE IS
SAYING IS REALLY A DIRECT
THREAT.
HE'S ORDERING HIS NUCLEAR
DETERRENT FORCES TO BE PUT ON
SPECIAL COMBAT REREGIME, A VERY
HIGH LEVEL OF ALERT.
THE REASON HE SAID THAT HE SAID
WE ARE HAVING AGGRESSIVE
STATEMENTS AND ACTIONS BY NATO
AND ALSO THESE SANCTIONS COMING
FROM THE UNITED STATES AND FROM
EUROPE.
AND YOU REALLY HAVE TO SAY THOSE
SANCTIONS ARE GOING TO VERY MUCH
BITE.
TONIGHT IT'S VERY LATE SUNDAY
NIGHT, EARLY MONDAY MORNING.
TOMORROW MORNING WHEN THE
MARKETS AND THE TRADING PLACES
WHERE RUSSIANS TRADE THEIR
RUBLES, IT COULD BE PRETTY GRIM.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT IS TRYING
TO RESPOND TO A LOT OF THIS, AND
THE UNITED STATES DID HAVE AN
ACTIVE RESPONSE, THE WHITE HOUSE
SAYING THIS IS ESSENTIALLY A
MANUFACTURED THREAT THAT REALLY
DOESN'T EXIST.
SO LUCKILY THERE DOESN'T SEEM TO
BE A TIT FOR TAT.
THE UNITED STATES COULD HAVE
WE'RE GOING TO GO ON SUPER ALERT
AS WELL, BUT THEY DID NOT DO
THAT, AT LEAST AT THIS POINT
THEY'RE NOT DOING THAT.
ANOTHER THING, JIM, I THINK IS
NOTABLE.
WE'VE BEEN WATCHING A LOT OF
RUSSIAN REPORTS ON RUSSIAN
STATE-OWNED AND OPERATED TV.
AND THEY HAVE THIS KIND OF
DIVIDED VERSION OF WHAT THE
UKRAINIAN FORCES ARE.
IN THEIR REPORTS FROM THE
EASTERN PART FROM THAT DONBAS
BREAKAWAY REGION THEY'RE
DEPICTING THEM -- THEY NEVER
CALL THEM THE UKRAINIAN ARMY.
THEY CALL THEM NATIONALISTS.
AND THEY DEPICT THEM AS FIERCE
MONSTERS WHO KILL AND ATTACK
PEOPLE.
AND THEN THE OTHER IMAGE IS OF
REGULAR UKRAINIAN FORCES IN
AREAS WE'VE BEEN REPORTING ON,
KYIV AND OTHER MAIN CITIES, AND
THEY ARE DEPICTED BY THE
RUSSIANS AS WEAKLINGS WHO GIVE
UP AND TURN OVER TO THE RUSSIAN
FORCES, SURRENDERING.
IT'S A VERY ODD VISION.
AND SO TODAY THAT ALL CAME
TOGETHER AS THE MILITARY
BRIEFED, AS IT DOES EVERY DAY,
AND FOR THE FIRST TIME ADMITTED
THEY ACTUALLY HAVE LOST FORCES.
THEY'VE BEEN KILLED.
THEY'VE BEEN WOUNDED, BUT THERE
WERE NO NUMBERS THEY GAVE.
I THINK THAT IS SIGNIFICANT THAT
THEY DID ADMIT THAT'S HAPPENING.
THEY ADDED, OF COURSE, IT'S FAR
FEWER THAN THE UKRAINIANS ARE
HAVING KILLED AND WOUNDED.
JIM?
>> AND, JILL, THESE PROTESTS
THAT HAVE BEEN CROPPING UP IN
RUSSIA JUST REMARKABLE TO SEE.
TYPICALLY WE DON'T SEE THIS SORT
OF THING.
WE'RE SHOWING SOME PICTURES NOW
OF WHAT CAME IN OUT OF ST.
PETERSBERG TODAY AND RUSSIAN
POLICE GOING IN THERE AND JUST
ROUGHING UP THESE PROTESTERS,
BUT THEY'RE LOCKING ARMS IN
THESE IMAGES WE'RE SHOWING OUR
VIEWERS AND SEEM VERY DETERMINED
TO MAKE THEIR VOICES HEARD.
>> Reporter: THEY ARE AND
THEY'RE ACTUALLY VERY BRAVE TO
DO THAT BECAUSE EVER SINCE THE
PROTESTS NOT TOO LONG AGO THE
OPPOSITION LEADER WHO IS NOW IN
PRISON WORK CAMP, AND IT HAS
GOTTEN MORE AND MORE, I WOULD
SAY, REPRESSIVE AND ACTUALLY
VERY BRUCEAL.
YOU CAN LOOK AT SOME OF THAT
FOOTAGE AND THAT IS MEANT -- YOU
TAKE THESE OF SOME OF THE YOUNG
PEOPLE, PUT THEM IN DETENTION.
THEY'RE HELD FOR SOMETIMES A
COUPLE OF DAYS.
SOMETIMES IN CONDITIONS THAT ARE
NOT VERY GOOD.
AND THEN THEY ARE WARNED THAT
THIS WILL BE A BLACK MARK ON
YOUR WORK RECORD, ON YOUR SCHOOL
RECORD, AND THAT IS ONE WAY
THEY'RE TRYING TO CONVINCE YOUNG
PEOPLE NOT TO GET INVOLVED IN
THIS.
THIS IS AN ANTI-WAR MOVEMENT
YOU'D HAVE TO SAY.
IT IS NOT THE MAJORITY OF
RUSSIANS, WE HAVE TO S